الذي ينعقد في دورتها الحاليه بمدينه شرم
الشيخ
مدينه السلام
والى المدن المصريه التي تعرف طريقها نحو
التحول الاخضر
وظروف مواتيه للحياه والعمل والنمو دون
ادرار بموارد عالمنا
التي يتعين العمل على تنميهها واستثمارها
وجعلها اكثر استدامه
ان الملايين اليوم
تتابعنا كما تبعت قيمتنا العام الماضي من
نساء ورجال وشباب واطفال
مزارعين وعمال واصحاب اعمال
بشر من سائر انحاء كوكبنا
يشتركون في مصير واحد
وهدف واحد
منهم من يتواجدون معنا هنا
ومنهم منهم خارج هذه القاعات وامام
الشاشات
يطرحون علينا اسئله صعبه
ولكنها ضروريه
اسئله
يتعين علينا ان نسالها لانفسنا قبل ان
توجه الينا
هل نحن اليوم
اقرب الى تحقيق اهدافنا من عام مضى
هل استطعنا خلال العام المنصرم ان نتحمل
مسؤوليتنا كقاده للعالم في التعامل مع
اخطر قضايا القرن واشدها تاثيرا
والسؤال الاهم
الذي يتعين ان وجهه لانفسنا
هل ما نطمح الى تحقيقه من اهداف
يقع في نطاق الممكن
بلا شك انه ليس مستحيلا
ولكن اذا توفرت الاراده الحقيقيه
والنيه الصادقه
لتعزيز العمل المناخي المشترك
وترجمه ما يصدر عن اجتماعاتنا من نتائج
الى واقع ملبوس
اثق في انكم هنا اليوم
من اجل الاجابه عن تلك الاسئله
والرد على شواغل الملايين حول العالم
الذين يعانون الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى من
كوارث مناخيه تتصارع وترتها
وتزداد حدتها على نحو غير مسبوق
يوما بعد يوم
في شتى انحاء كوكبنا
فما تلبس ان تنتهي كارثه في مكان ما حتى
تبدا اخرى في مكان اخر
مخلفه ورائها الاف الضحايا والمصابين
والنازحين
ومسببه خسائر ماديه بالمليارات
وكان العالم قد اصبح مسرح مصر
وهنا علينا ان نتوقف
لنطرح نحن على انفسنا تساؤلا ملحن
اما انا لهذه المعاناه ان تنتهي
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
انما يحتاجه عالمنا اليوم
تتجاوز ازمه المناخ الراهنه
وللصول الى ما توافقنا عليه
كاهف في اتفاق باريس
يتجاوز مجرد الشعارات والكلمات
ان ما تنتظره منا شعوبنا اليوم
هو التنفيذ السريع والفعال والعادل
تتوقع منا شعوبنا خطوات حقيقيه
تغير المناخ
وتوفير التمويل اللازم للدول الناميه التي
تعاني اكثر من غيرها من ازمه المناخ
الراهنه
من هذا المنطلق علاقات حرسنا
على تسميه هذه القمه قمه التنفيذ
وهو الهدف الذي يجب ان تتمحور حوله كافه
جهودنا ومساعنا
وعلى الرغم من كافه التحديات التي
يواجهناها خلال الفتره الماضيه
فضلا عن جميع العوامل التي اعلموا انها
تلقي بظلال من الشك وعدم اليقين اذا
قدرتنا على الوصول الى اهداف اتفاق باريس
وحمايه كوكبنا من مستقبل
يصل فيه ارتفاع درجات الحراره
الى درجه مئويه
على الرغمى من ذلك كله
فانه هناك شواهد وعوامل اخرى
تدعونا الى التمسك
بالامل
في قدره البشريه
مستقبل افضل لاجيال القادمه لا يجب عليها
ان تتحمل نتائج اخطاء لم ترتكبها
وفي شعوب باتت اكثر وعيا ودرايه بحجم
التحدي
ومتطلبات مواجهته
وبالثمن الباهظ للتقاعد او التراجع
والامر ايضا في حكومات
ها وفي قطاع اعمال عالمي ومجتمع المدني
في هذا الاطار
ولقد ودعنا في مصر نصب اعيوننا اهدافا
طموحا
عبرنا عنها في استراتيجيه مصر الوطنيه
لمواجهه تغير المناخ
ونعمل على الاسراع من وتيره التحول الاخضر
من خلال التوسع في الاعتماد
على الطاقه المتجدده والنقل النظيف
بما يساهم في تعزيل الاستثمارات الخضراء
ولعل برنامج الوطنيه
من ضروري التنفيذ الفعلي على الارض
وخير دليل على ان الامل في التغلب على
تحدي تغير المناخ لا يزال قائما
اذا ما توافرت الاراده والعزيمه
و لعلكم تتفقون معي انه اذا كنا نرغب
حقيقه في السير معا نحو مستقبل
مضمن فيه ان تبقى درجات الحراره عند مستوى
ما يدور الدرجتين مئويه
مستقبل للجميع وبالجميع فانه واجبي يحتم
علي ان اصالحكم ببعض الشواغل
التي لابد ان لا نغفلها او نتناسى وجودها
وهي ان قدرتنا كمجتمع دولي على المضيء
بشكل موحد ومتسق نحو تنفيذ التزاماتنا
وتعهداتنا
وفقا لاتفاق باريس انما يراهن بمقدار
الثقه التي نتمكن من بنائها فيما بيننا
ومن ثم بينه من الضروري ان تشعر كافه
الاطراف من الدول الناميه خاصه في قريتنا
الافريقيه ان اولوياتها يتم التجاوب معها
واخذها في الاعتبار
انها تتحمل مسؤولياتها بقدر امكانياتها
وبقدر ما تحصل عليه من دعم وتمويل مناسبين
وفقا لمبدا المسؤوليه المشتركه
متباينه الاعداء
موقعها في هذا الجهد العالمي
لمواجهه تغيير المناخ وان ذلك لن يتاتى
سواء من خلال تهيئه مناخ من الثقه
المتبادله
ايضا بدون قيام الدول المتقدمه
التي اخذتها على نفسها
في تمويل المناخ ودعم جهود التكيف
والتعامل مع قضيه الخسائر والاضرار
الناجمه عن تغير المناخ في الدول الناميه
والاقل نموه
لتحقيق الانتقال المتوازن نحو الاقتصاد
الاخضر
لهذه الدول
انه وجودكم هنا اليوم في حد ذاته رساله
تاكيد على الاهتمام الذي لعمل المناخ
العالمي الذي ارجو ان ينعكس في اتساق
مواقف دوليكم
مع عنوان قمتنا وهو التنفيذ عنوان قمتنا
وهو التنفيذ
وتوجه اليكم اليوم مناشدا
ان تكون رسائلكم الى العالم الذي يتوقع من
الكثير رسائل واضحه
تتضمن خطوات محدده
لتنفيذ الالتزامات والتعهدات
مقترحا عليكم الاعلان عن المزيد من
المساهمات المحدده وطنيا
ورفع طموح استراتيجتكم لقدم
مبادرات طموحه وفعاله
تجمع كافه الفاعلين حول اهداف واضحه في
التكيفي والتمويل
من مبادرات في السابق
والانضمام الى المبادرات الجديده التي
تعتزم مصر اطلاقها على مدار ايام المؤتمر
والاهم من ذلك كله ان تكون توجهاتكم
لمفوضيكم الذين يستعدون الان لبدء اسبوعين
من المفاوضات المهمه هي التحلي بالمرونه
والعمل على بناء الثقه والتوافق
للخروج بالنتائج التي اعلم انكم كقاده
للعالم
تريدون الخروج بها من هذا المؤتمر
الذي احدثكم عنه اليوم ليس امل التمني بل
هو امل العمل والقدره على الفعل
لقد استطاعت الكثير من دولنا على مدار
العام الماضي ان تكون نماذج مضيئه
لهذا العمل وهذه القدره
مرضيه النحو الامام في تنفيذ تعهداتها
والتزاماتها
بالرغم من كافه الصعام
انني ادعوكم هنا من هنا ان احتذي بهذه
النماذج ولا تسمح لاي عوامل المناخ
الذي لن يتراجع او يتوقف دون تدخل منه
اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو
عند الوقت يداهمنا
ونهايه هذا العقد الحاسن ماتت على بعد
سنوات قليله علينا ان نستغلها
لنحسن خلالها هذه المعركه على النحو الذي
نريده ونرتضيه حان الوقت وقت العمل ذلك
ليرسي اجيال المستقبل من ابنائنا واحفادنا
اثق في حكمتكم وفي ادراككم لهذه اللحظه
المصريه من عمر كوكبنا
واعلم اننا جميعا اهل المسؤوليه
جها والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ايه ده نتابعنا معكم بدء فعاليات اعمال
القمه على مستوى القاده قمه المناخ
السابعه والعشرين في شرم الشيخ
ولا انا حضور كريم من قاده العالم
لهذا المؤتمر
اكبر حجم
معذره يعني من القاده قاده الدول ملوك
ورؤساء ورؤساء حكومات موجودين الان معنا
عشان نناقش مشكله كبيره جدا
بتقابلنا
وهتقابلنا لكن انا هاتكلم معكم النهارده
احنا محتاجين
نتحرك نعمل
ندعو
لي
انا باتكلم على ازمه كبيره بتمر بالعالم
ولها تاثير كبير جدا على دول كثير من
العالم اللي ما كانش كل دول العالم انا
باتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وبوجه النداء
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من فضلكم
نحن
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه كرونه سنتين
وتحملناها
والان معاني ايضا من هذه الحرب
انا باقول ثاني احنا مستعدين انا
سمحت
هذا نداء من مؤتمرنا هنا
بالمناسبه انا مستعد ومش
مش للبحث عن دور لا والله ولكن من اجل
العمل
يشاركون الرائده احنا مستعدين نتحرك اذا
كان ده ممكن لايقاف هذه الحرب اشكركم
وارجو ان اكون قد اثقلت عليكم مرحبا بكم
في مصر في شرم الشيخ والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]